And today we're gonna talk about a very good movie, a movie from 1999. So around the millennia transition and the next millennia, which is The Runaway Bride. And as I already said, I like the movie. It's a great movie. And I used it already as an example to explain some things earlier.
About Jungian psychology because you have it in some movies that you can really explain very well or showcase what Jung tried to say with a certain concept. It's easier in a story. Always, everything is easier in a story. And I've done this before. I've done this for Barbie the movie, also for Titanic. I did it for Fight Club.
Like a month ago, I did it for American Psycho, which was a very good event. And this time it's Runaway Bride, a romantic comedy and an interesting psychological development and also view into how relationships work and how, yeah, the psyche changes through other people.
This is why I gave it the subtitle Becoming Oneself Through Others. And when we talk about Jung, we talk about archetypes and there are some things that are very archetypal, meaning those are experiences that happened so often in human history that they became ingrained in our psychology and we really like to experience them in art and culture.
And in this movie, it's clearly people falling in love and people marrying. So the whole movie is about doing this ultimate commitment to a single person. Marrying them, and of course the falling in love part that happens before. And the movie is with Richard Gere as Ike and Julia Roberts as Maggie.
And I tried to summarize it in like 2, 3 sentences. The New York writer Ike brings country girl Maggie to introspection about her own wishes and dreams. In this process, both fall for each other. Can Maggie overcome her old patterns to find true love?
And the reason why I always use this example to showcase certain concepts of Jung, I wanted to bring here, and this has to do with the eggs. This is the preferences of Maggie in regards how she likes her breakfast eggs. And I have a quote. Eros without the Logos inside never understands.
There is nothing but blind relatedness. Such people can be related to God knows what, like certain women who are dissolved completely in little happy families, cousins, relations, and there's nothing in the whole damn thing. It is all perfectly empty.
And this is also the quote of the event, and it describes this phenomena that Maggie experiences, but Ike becomes aware of, which is she has a preference for the breakfast eggs based on her partner.
Like, Ike goes around and asks people a lot of things, but one weird question in the end is like, okay, how did she like her breakfast eggs? And they always say like, oh, she liked it just like me. They were like scrambled, brushed, whatever. And this really makes Ike curious about, okay, that is weird. Like, How can this preference change based on the partner?
And the movie is very close to the end where Maggie realizes what kind of eggs she likes. This is why she tries all the different eggs, does it at once, and then goes to him and say like, I like eggs Benedict the best. And this is the sign like, okay, now she has understood like what she really wants. She found her own preferences, her own psychology.
And yeah, this is then almost close to the movie and concluding everything until almost the wedding. And to describe the patterns she is going through psychological-wise through the movie and the patterns she is resolving, I have another quote, which is a, a little bit more famous about Jung, from Jung.
It is, until you make the unconscious conscious, it will direct your life and you will call it fate. So what Maggie is doing is, uh, repeating a certain pattern that she is not aware of. And it takes Ike as an external person to make her aware of her own patterns and behavior so that she becomes questioning that and then change the behavior and breaking out of that.
And she is unaware, she's oblivious, she's unconscious about what is happening in her life and what is happening inside of her. And this is what Jung means with this, and this is what has done a lot with his patients that came to him always with problems in their life and living their life, that they have certain patterns that they follow and they're not aware of.
And his job was to make them aware of that so that they could transcend that and become more themselves. Every movie has an arc describing that characters are changing through the events of the movie. And they're changing their patterns of behavior and they're changing their psychology. This is described as an arc.
And because we have a romance story here, a lot of romance stories are about both people changing at the same time. So both people influence each other positively and like in Hollywood speak, that would be a two-hander. So we have an arc for Maggie and we have an arc for Ike.
And Maggie starts out as being completely entangled in their partner's psychology with the problem that she cannot commit. Like she can be part of the life, she can get engaged, they can live together, do everything together up to the point where it's really commitment for life, being married. And this is the point where she runs away.
And this is what she becomes famous for in the movie and even outside of her small town. Until New York that she's showing this behavior again and again and again. And through the events of the movie, she starts confronting the fact that she has a negative influence, that she causes hurt feelings in those people around her.
And she did not notice that before. And she finds out what she really wants and what her preferences are and trying to lead her own life. And this is then really the point where she's able to become a whole human being and able then to commit and go into this relationship. So it is for her really in the beginning, she has all these very different men.
Like one is a sportsman, one is a musician, one is studying locusts, and, uh, she's completely happy with them until the point where it's really then the commitment and then she runs away. But even then, she's not really fully committed. Like, the artist, the musician, was really surprised that she did not have the tattoo on her back.
Like, that is what, like, a printed-on tattoo that she then removed. And from a Jungian perspective, there is something in the background of her mind, there's something in her unconscious that is telling her, like, okay, this is not right, and this Then takes over, like something inside her tells her that she is not ready. Something makes her hesitate.
And Jung very often calls this the Self, which is like the, the future you, like also a kind of moral instance. So our conscience comes from there. It reminds us of how things actually should be. It's like a judge inside of one, or like a moral compass that points out where we stray.
And you find that pretty often in stories and like psychological stories that people struggle with their conscience, more often negative consequences, like doing bad things, like in Crime and Punishment, Raskolnikov struggles a lot that he killed someone, even though that he got away with it. Here it's running away from weddings, which is not as drastic as doing criminal acts.
And a confrontation really is about That she goes in the past and she tries to talk with her ex-fiancés who tell her like how much they've been hurt. And she's like, oh yeah, it was not so bad. And they're like, oh yeah, it was bad. And that she's even kind of flirting with the husband of her best friend who she has been in the relationship with.
That was the guy playing baseball and being completely unaware about that. So like people around her notice it, but she does not really notice it in herself.
And the interesting thing, the really interesting thing, if we look at it through a Jungian lens, where I had to smile, like she goes to one of her ex-boyfriends and fiancés who is a Catholic priest now, and she goes there and confesses. And why I have to smile when I say that.
Because Jung talked a lot about the fact that like in the past there were certain psychological institutions and like traditions that help people dealing with their psychological troubles. And he said one of big, very big instance and institution was the confession and the Catholic Church.
Like you have a secret, you have something inside you that burdens you and you unburden yourself with telling someone else about it. So she already does this like automatically. And Jung would say, okay, this we don't have anymore.
This is why we now have psychology and therapists so that people can have this talking cure and unburden themselves from pressing things that press down on them. But she feels the weight suddenly. In contrast to that, we have Ike, played by Richard Gere.
And Ike starts out as a New York writer who has a column and does not really write personal stuff. It's all very impersonal and it's all, let's say, negatively geared towards women. And this shows in his life as he has a failed marriage and even works with his ex-wife together.
And there's something else that made me smile when he wrote the column about Maggie. He talked about the female archetype.
So he talked about the mother, the virgin, the whore, the crone, all still being alive and describing Maggie in that way that she's a kind of man-eater like Kali is, or all these other negative anima representations that basically chew up men and spit them out. And yeah, leave not a lot of that there.
And it seems like it really triggered him and that kicked off the story by him being fired for his views because they were a little bit too extreme in the public eye. And also he did not check because he was strongly emotionally involved. So he goes there to, goes to Maggie to expose her and achieve the exact opposite.
Like he falls for Maggie, he stands up for her, and he feels for her a lot because kind of everybody in the town is picking on her. And teasing her and making fun of her. And it affects her even though that she does not show it. And he tries really to understand and investigate, which is something that her boyfriends and ex-fiancés did not do.
Like, they were completely fine with having someone who does just like the same things, does the same things. And then they were really surprised when that person did not want to marry them. But yeah, so like, Ike really cares for her. And this is how he loses his cynicism in the end.
He finds love, he reconciles, and yeah, in the end they can both become married because they feel for each other and care for each other's feeling. And he's also the only guy who runs after her when she run away. Like all the other guys, they did not run after her. So this brings us to Maggie and Ike. And their relationship.
And Jung talked a lot about relationships. This is what I have with the quotes here. You can only learn who you are through your efforts on other people. By this means, you create your personality. Also, only different things can enter into relationship. And you can be in a relationship with someone without taking on their personality. You can't.
So what I do, I have a whole list and, uh, like catalog of different quotes categorized based on certain topics. And I also there, I have to smile when I find things that are really perfectly describing what we have in, uh, the story or the movie. And this is basically what Maggie is doing.
Maggie is trying to perceive herself through other people, which is not what she did before. She tries to understand what Ike is going for, what Ike is investigating.
This is also why she breaks into his hotel room and steals his thoughts by taking all these Post-its to try to understand herself through the eyes of other people, which is already a pretty good way to do it because other people are more aware of where one's own shortcomings are. And Jung talks about that a lot.
Like, people have blind spots about themselves, about their personalities, about their worldview. What we have as an adaptation to the world and to relationships is consciousness, but it is not complete. It's not everything. There's always something missing. And this is why we kind of need other people to tell us where we are wrong.
And there we have to be open and listen to and follow that. And for Jung, this is a big role in, in a therapy setting where this relationship can have been broken down with another normal environment.
Like the task that Jung saw for himself was to bring people back into their normal life and also bring them into, let's say, harmony with themselves so that they have access again to this voice of consciousness and that they can understand it and live a normal life. So Jung is also famous for the shadow.
So the hidden parts that are hidden for us, but that confronts us and wear down on us. And he says it's way easier to see the shadow in other people than to see the shadow in us. So it has to be other people there.
It has to be this kind of exchange of ideas and views to bring those things back into the fold, back into the personality that should be there anyways, but they're not for some reason. For some reason, Maggie is not aware of what she's doing, and this is why she needs other people. And this is only why it works with Ike, because Ike, he cares.
He really tries to see and understand her, and he notices that she's just following along, but everyone else does not question it really. That she, like, all her wedding rings look different. All her weddings look different. All her wedding dresses look different. All her hobbies suddenly are different and no one really questions it.
So they are all also in their own way unconscious. And there Ike comes to basically not only change Maggie, but also by standing up for her, changing the views of the town and also her family about her. The second quote is of course also on point. Only different things can enter relationship.
It is that Maggie follows along and Maggie starts to change, and then they quickly, very quickly want to marry, Ike and Maggie. And of course it does not work because it's the same pattern again. Like she has not really changed. She became aware of her own problems, but she immediately fell into a pattern, which is like falling in love with the next guy.
Like this is how it's described. Like she is at the wedding, but she already has a backup that she can run away with. And that backup and last planned wedding with Bob is Ike. And this is why this marriage or wedding falls apart, because it's just the same pattern again. It does not matter, like, how much Ike wants it.
Maggie has not changed it yet, has not changed herself. So it's only after she runs away that she starts her self-discovery journey, that she starts to investigate what she wants. And what she wants is this creative personal act of the lamps that she's building herself and she starts selling them.
And this is something removed from her job where she works in a hardware store where she actually did not want to work, but it was the store of her father. So she was there to support. Again, like being entangled, coming back to the first quote of the event, being entangled in the psychology of other people, may it be in the romantic partner, but also be it in the parents.
So not knowing what oneself wants because one is only concerned about the personality of those surrounding one and thus being unconscious. And it's only then when she's realized what she wants that she switches around.
She is not a passive part, receiving part, receiving preferences, marriages happening to her, weddings happening to her. Relationships happening to her, but rather actively seeking out a person to have a relationship with them and proposing to them. So it's a switch around of roles that she in the end proposes to Ike.
And this is the important part because now she's a personality. Now she knows what she wants and has a feeling for herself, and she can formulate her own wishes and desires, which before she was likely not even aware of. So she proposes and says like, yeah, I want a private marriage. Like, I don't want anybody to be there except for like you and the pastor.
And this is what happens in the end. And this is then when it works out. This is when the pattern is broken. When she transformed, she can do this step and go into a marriage. Yeah. And you can't be really in a relationship with someone that aren't taking on their personality.
So everyone who's been in a very long-term relationship, it starts like the, the two psychologies start intertwining more and more. Like you, you build like a model of the other person inside your head and take over mannerisms, ideas, thoughts. Yeah, it becomes part of one's psychology.
And Jung talks about that, and this quote, sadly, I could not find, but he said this is also why there's relationship trouble. Like, when people realize that they become too much alike, when they become too involved with each other, they're too close, let's say. They're not different enough because only different things can enter a relationship.
Meaning that when you have a love and a love story, we have very often this meet-cute or like this conflict and adversary between the two future lovers, this has to do with the fact, like, they're feeling that something is entering their psychology and they're feeling that there is a relationship forming that might overwhelm them.
Like, falling in love for Jung is a perfect example for a complex taking over the psyche, taking over thoughts, dreams, and so on. So yeah, getting lost in a relationship is not something too unusual and losing oneself.
So the, the thing that Ike is doing is make her reflect on herself, reflect on her action, on her past, and he fulfills a function that Jung very often saw in the patients he had by things that they did automatically. And I have a quote for that.
This always takes place when the way ahead is not free, when there is an obstacle from which you recoil, or when you need to get something out of the past in order to climb over the wall ahead. And he called this phenomena very often regression, which means people have something in their life that they need to do. So he says, life wants to move forward.
Like, your psychology is built to move forward, and it does a lot of things all by itself. Like, Hitting puberty, you have no say in it, right? And growing up and also getting old, like the, the, all these things happen without one agreeing to them, but like this is what the body does. This is what the psyche does. So there's always tasks ahead.
And the question is like whether our ego, our consciousness, we as persons are willing to do those steps. And what he sees then very often or saw in his patients was that they were hitting a certain roadblock in life. And there was an obstacle that they cannot overcome. And all this energy that would move forward suddenly flows back.
It flows into the past and activates it. This is when people become really, really interested in their childhoods, but their past in general, because they want to figure something out. They want to understand, okay, something happened here and I'm not completely sure what. He says that can be useful, but also like everything gets activated.
So there could be also a lot of stuff in there, but this is then what, what Maggie is doing, right? She wants to marry, she wants to commit, otherwise she would not say that she wants to do it, but unlikely, but she cannot do it.
She always hits this roadblock that she cannot pull through and say yes and then be be in the committed long-term relationship. And it is an Ike that is a bad omen and a bad sign that this might happen again because he's there to witness it. Like, this is his mission. He wants to visit it, witness it. He wants to prove himself right and her wrong and get his job back.
This is why he travels to her. And he goes through her past, and by that way, she needs to reflect on her own past and talk with her ex-fiancés. And this is when she realizes all the let's say, hurt that she caused and also all the trouble, completely misunderstanding or realizing that she misunderstood the situations.
And the funny thing is, like, when she broke into the hotel room of Ike, she's hiding in the toilet because he came back and he bangs on the door and says, open up. And that's pretty much on the nose. He wants her to open up. He wants her to realize what's happening around her and also to realize more about herself.
And yeah, she does that by trying to steal his thoughts.
And when we look into masculine and feminine, which is like the love story, relationships between men and women, Jung sees there two underlying forces at play, psychological forces that are not completely limited to, to men and women, but rather those are psychological forces that are in everyone. And one of that is Logos and one of them is Eros.
And Jung describes it like that: Eros is an interweaving. Logos is differentiating knowledge, clarifying light. Eros is relatedness. Logos is discrimination and detachment. One can already see here, like, where Ike and Maggie would stand.
Like, Maggie is this interviewing part, relationship part, becoming intertwined with the psychology of other people and relating to them. Ike is pretty much isolated.
Like, Ike is not even very much liked in New York, but what he does is He's differentiating, he's bringing to light, he's, yeah, detaching also from things, but also detaching her. So what they both do, they help each other out. They have this incredibly cute idea from ancient Greek philosophy.
I think it's from Plato, and it has to do with that when human beings were created, they had four arms, four legs, four heads. And basically you have these kind of round people that would turn wheels all day and would be very happy and would be very content. And the gods saw that and they really did not like it because the gods do not like when they're happy human beings.
So Zeus threw a lightning bolt and split them in half. So suddenly you have two human beings with two legs, two arms, and one head each. And What they needed to do, what their life story would be, is trying to find the other part to become a complete human being again.
So what's happening there is that each is bringing something to the table, as we would say today, and what they're psychologically fit to do. So like Logos and Eros is both in each human being, but he says men are more on the Logos side and women are more on the Eros side.
But both together, when they're in a relationship, they complement each other and they develop each other. They help the other person out with the thing that they're, which is on the weaker side, you would call it inferior side.
So when you have two people, one is left-handed, one is right-handed, like if you put them together, you have someone who can work with both hands pretty well to give an easy picture. And he would see this Logos and Eros represented in people themselves in the anima or animus figure. This is also very famous terms of Jung.
And you would have that in love stories. Like if you have a love story from the point of view of a man, then the woman he's wanting and he's looking for is the anima. And the other way around, like in a woman's story, it is then the animus that is searched for. And it is to gain insight and get this other part into one's psychology, which is missing. Is it Logos or Eros?
And what we see in Maggie is like a detached Logos that is shown in a kind of Jungian concept, animus possession. And I have a quote for that here. I've seen cases of women possessed by the animus, who then told me longstanding stories of relationships that all went sour.
And in the end, they stand there empty-handed, completely isolated, and surrounded nothing by countless devils. It's not that bad for Maggie. Not maybe yet. But this is also not something unusual for men. Like, he would call it anima possession, like if Men would look out and just have countless relationships with women.
That being a sign that there's something missing, they're looking for something, but that something is not really found in another person per se. And like, it's not that this is a complete person that they're looking for, but rather there's a missing part in their psychology they're trying to find this Logos part or this Eros part. And this is why it's a fruitless endeavor.
This is why you cannot find like the perfect partner in that sense to fill out a psychological need. And this is why Maggie is then switching and switching and switching because she is looking for something. She's not aware of what she's looking for, but at the moment where it comes to the commitment, she really realizes like, okay, this is not it. Like I have to get out.
I have to basically do it again. But she does repeat this pattern then again and again, jumping from man to man. What is interesting about her is she is pretty masculine in her, in her interests and in her job. Like she does kickboxing, she repairs cars, she works in the shop of her father. And those are many things that she picked up from her father.
So her father's psychology has a huge influence on her. In a, let's say, overbearing way also. Jung would see this often with his patients. Like Jung started in psychoanalysis, like he was a friend with Freud over a long time.
So the father or the mother complex where the parent has an, let's say, a negative influence on the psychology of the child is absolutely nothing unusual that he saw there. So she, this was also when they were riding in the car that she told the story like how she came back to help out her father. And this is what she's doing.
Like he's helping her out, her father run the store. She's helping out her father who's getting drunk constantly. And she tolerates like all the negative things that he is saying. Like he's making all these jokes about her. On the one side, he's very understanding and very kind and supportive and so on.
But then like he makes a lot of jokes about her in front of other people and she's bothered by that, but she's not saying anything. And this is also a sign of her developmental progress and development that she's confronting her father and telling her, I do not like this, please stop.
So that's the thing that, for example, Jordan Peterson also talks about, who also worked as a therapist, that he says when A lot of people go into therapy because they're too agreeable, like they follow too much other people. And when they go through therapy, they become more assertive.
So they suddenly would confront, for example, their partners about behavior they did not like for the last 10 years, but did not speak out about. So this is then also what Maggie is doing and showing her psychological progress to becoming more an individual person. So Ike, and I find this kind of funny, is a representation of her animus, but also of Logos.
And what is Logos? Logos is the airy quality, the spiritual quality, the thing up high, a little bit abstract, but also Logos coming from Greek, meaning word, words, speech.
So he is a writer living in a big city far away in a penthouse up in the sky, and he has white hair, which in an alchemical sense is then the abstract Logos phase of the alchemical process.
I always say normally before that nobody really plans to write a story or a movie with strong Jungian symbolism and concepts behind it.
But things turn out this way because Jung really penetrated the psyche, the human psyche down to a point where he hit a layer of psychology where all culture is coming from. So he describes a thing there. So when people say like, I want to write a good story, or they're writing a good story, that this symbolism comes up.
So yeah, like Ike is pretty much a representation of Logos, a representation of the animus in a positive way. Of course, we have a lot of negative animus examples also. Those are then tyrants or brutal and cruel people. And for the negative anima, Ike talked about that when he talked about the crone and the witch and Kali and all these different things.
This is like the negative view one can have. Of women psychologically wise. And then again, it's interesting, Eros being associated with the earthly, the bodily, that Maggie is living in a farm in a rural town, and she has like brown hair like the earth.
She has brown eyes like the earth, and she has very hands-on job. And so it's always funny to see this kind of symbolism. Like, this is, this is just how human beings like to tell stories and how they like to see stories. So the journey that Maggie's on is called, for Jung, individuation.
And I have some quotes here to illustrate what he means by that concept. I use the term individuation to denote the process by which a person becomes a psychological individual, that is, a separate indivisible unity of whole. Another quote: We could therefore translate individuation as come to selfhood or self-realization.
And the third quote: The process of individuation, the step-by-step development of the self from an unconscious state to a conscious state, which all describes the story that Maggie's going through, but it, which is like an archetypal story of stories. Like you have that in a lot of movies, stories, theater plays that people go from one state in the next.
They go from a simpler state to a more complex state, right? Luke Skywalker starts out as a farm boy. In the end, he's a hero of the galaxy. You have Neo as a normal hacker guy. Then he becomes like the savior of humanity. Or you have psychological stories. For example, Jaws. It's a very, very psychological story.
But in the context of this movie, it is individuation, becoming an individual, meaning separated from others psychologically. That does not mean like physically separated. Maggie does not need to run away from all her relationships. Well, she kind of does from her fiancés to become herself.
Like she can be herself and also be in a relationship with someone else. So there's the kind of paradox there, but it's not mutually exclusive. But yeah, this is what Jung means with individuation, separated from different things.
May it be relationships outside, but also inside, like not being identical with certain emotions, like lust, anger, or envy, resentment, and so on, and let them dictate one's life. Then again, going back to this idea of until you make the unconscious conscious, It will dictate your life and you will call it fate.
So yeah, moving from an unconscious to a conscious state, to a more complete human being, to a more complete psychology, to do more and more sophisticated work. Like she's suddenly able to sell her lamps and following her passion. And also finally to get this marriage, which before she was not able to do.
Because she was not at this stage yet, because she was not, let's say, sophisticated enough in her consciousness and in her personality. Same for Ike. Like, Ike was downtrodden, negative, cynical about women and about the world. In the end, he finds a very nice woman and he really wants to marry her.
And yeah, he says yes when he's proposed to, and that's also completely fine for him. And when I talk about Jung and I'm getting asked sometimes, okay, Marcus, how did you pick the movies? And say like, oh yeah, there's some, just some movies where I have the strong feeling there are Jungian themes in there. And sometimes I have the feeling I get like paranoid or schizophrenic.
And I have to move here into alchemy, which is also a topic that Jung talked about a lot in a psychological sense. And there's a very old problem in Alchemical Studies, which is 3+1, which is like when you have 3, it's very hard to get the fourth. So when you have 1, the second one comes automatically.
The interplay between the two generates the third, but getting to the fourth, this is really the most difficult task of all. And in numerology, 4 is the number of wholeness. This is why like mandalas have 4 parts. And we speak of a quaternity. So this is when everything is in place, everything is in harmony.
This is when we've reached the number 4, and this is when, yeah, everything is properly integrated. So what the alchemists were trying to do is create gold. For Jung, psychological gold. For some other people, like real gold. And the problem was like they had all the different ingredients. They had sulfur, they had Mercurius, they had salt.
But what they're missing was the last thing, the fourth thing, and that is the lapis, the philosopher's stone. And this would then fulfill the alchemical process and fulfill this, yeah, potential that is inside the material world. And there's a lot of examples for that in, of course, again, culture.
So we have the Holy Trinity, the Father, the Son, the Holy Ghost. But like, what is missing in there? Sophia is missing, the wisdom of God, according to the Gnostic teachings, or the devil is missing there. Like, also kind of necessary to explain the world. You have the Three Musketeers, which is— how many musketeers are there in the Three Musketeers?
It's four, because the fourth one is D'Artagnan, who seeks out the three who are already there. In storytelling, you talk about the fourth wall. Meaning like the audience is being addressed directly. So basically looking through the screen. Some movies do that. Deadpool does this and Ferris Bueller Day Off, and also some series, uh, I think Fleabag.
And Jung talks about this in the inferior function saying, oh, we have four functions and the last one is always the hardest because this is strangest from them all. It is always that the fourth part is the strangest, weirdest. Darkest, ugliest, unfitting thing. So this is what always pushed away.
This is why in the Holy Trinity, like, it's all masculine, but the feminine is missing there because it's, ah, it does not fit completely. And this is why Jung said, okay, there's still room for development in Christianity and Christian thought because the feminine is just lacking, the bodily, the earthly.
And why I'm saying this in the context of this movie, because Maggie had 3 failed marriage and wedding attempts. And the movie is basically about the fourth, which is first with Bob, but she falls in love with Ike. Ike tries to also marry her in the same way, and this does not work.
So it has to be the fourth, and the fourth attempt then works. And the fourth one is completely different. She proposes to the man. She is changed psychologically. She marries without other people there, which is different from all the other things. And this is what completes her. Like, this is then the relationship and the things she needed to become complete.
And I watched the movie and I thought, this is the alchemical problem. And this is where I have to say like, okay, maybe become a little bit paranoid, starting to see patterns that are maybe not there. But then I would go like, okay, yeah, maybe, maybe it's just what drawn people to that. Like it's not completely random that she had 3 wedding attempts.
It's then the 4th one, which is then completely different. And that is then what works. And this is the thing that would have not been expected in the beginning. So that's pretty cool. And this is why I wanted to teach you alchemy at the end of a long working day. And I want to come back to, uh, what I started with initially. We have an archetypal event here.
We have relationship, which ends in the wedding, which is the basis for a lot of stories, also fairy tales. Like most fairy tales end like this, that it ends with a wedding. And I have a quote from Jung for that. The chief reason is that as an analyst, I'm usually confronted with the most amazing fact. That when man and woman meet, some trouble results.
It is generally true that the relationship between man and woman is not simple, but I quite understand that such a bold statement is irritating since we are all perfectly convinced that this should not be so. As you know, we chiefly think the things we like to think and dislike to think. Such irritating truths as trouble arising from love or friendship.
Naturally, we dislike such statements. Yet if we look at the world objectively, We must ask ourselves why such an important religion as Christianity invented particular rites or particular ideas around marriage and not only Christianity. It's true.
When we look into human cultures, like the concept of marriage, we have it in all cultures to long-term monogamous relationships between man and a woman and giving their vows in front of other people. As a commitment, public commitment, is so ingrained in our psychology and so archetypal that we seek out for it.
But also, we are like hyper interested in that. In the movie, the fact that she cannot commit becomes a public topic in her town, but even outside of town. Like in New York, very far away, in a newspaper where everybody can read it.
And everyone reads about the woman who cannot commit and why that is, because let's say that's not the way how it's supposed to be. It is not fulfilling this expectation of this archetypal arrangement. And this is why people in the movie and story are following it so closely and then celebrating when it finally works.
But at the same time, we as the audience also watch this movie to see this happen. Like the love stories, we see them to get them together. In modern movies, not so much that they get married in the end, but like as an archetypal story, yes. And what is Carl Gustav Jung describing here is, is a true thing.
Like when men and women meet, there is something happening and trouble ensuing. And yeah, it's then very. Difficult, let's say, to formalize. And this interest we see everywhere in our daily life.
Just recently, I think last week, Jeff Bezos married, and it was so important that the whole world had to report about the richest man in the world marrying nonstop. And all the things have been done, and people are glued to the screens.
And like when there's royal weddings, like there are millions and millions and millions of people watching because this is what is archetypally, psychologically in us to like see, experience, and what we are drawn to. And this is why you can make a great movie about a woman who does not commit. Like, who cares? Let's say in an abstract sense, but yeah, we, we care.
And out comes a pretty good movie. So, and this is also why everybody immediately when they see Ike and her together, like they see, oh, there's something brewing. There's something happening here. Again, like, other people can be smarter than oneself. And this is then the story of the movie.
And I want to talk a little bit about the movie itself as a movie, because I watched it again, and I watched it a long time ago, and watching it a little bit older, I had to say, my God, Everyone is incredibly emotionally mature. Like everybody's incredibly stable. Like nobody's screaming at each other. Nobody is trying to guilt trip another person.
And everybody's very understanding. Like even her ex-fiancés, of course they're a little bit hurt, but they also have new relationships and that's fine. Like you see in the end, like all these different people coming together, kind of also unified. By this archetypal act that Maggie and Ike are doing. And yeah, there's apologizing, there's acceptance of apology.
And I watched this and said like, there's not so much drama in here actually. Like normally in a movie or a story, you try to have as much drama as possible. And this is actually what then a lot of say modern stories are about. Like people just treating each other poorly.
And I have to say on a personal note, that makes it for me very difficult to see a lot of like modern entertainment because it's like people, you watch people being awful to each other for 2 hours. And I watched the movie, it's like, oh, that's so nice.
Like everybody's so mature and treating each other pretty well and just dealing pretty well with all the troubles that are there, which are not actually that big. And I was surprised when I looked and the movie got pretty bad reviews. And I did not expect that because I liked the movie a lot. I liked it already many years ago a lot. And people say it's boring.
Like this is, I read the reviews and a lot of people are saying, oh, this is boring. Nothing is happening and all these different things. And I think about, yeah, maybe that's true. Maybe this is why it's badly rated because it's a pretty mature movie about like adults finding love and marrying and being kind of nice to each other.
There's not so much drama in there and awful heartbreak and all these other things. Yeah. And one point I found very poignant and interesting when they fought for each other, Ike and Maggie, and they're outside of this church and Bob, like her fiancé, just ran away.
They, they kiss intensively, but they pull apart and he says, okay, we really need to talk. We have to think like, oh, that's a very mature thing to do. Like to say, it's not only the passions, there needs something more. It cannot only be relatedness. It cannot only be Eros, but there has to be also Logos separating. There has to be bringing to light. There has to be words.
So both things are necessary from both sides intermingling, but they have to be there equally. It cannot be only be into a relationship like it is for Maggie. It can not only this impersonal tearing apart as Ike is doing it, but rather it has to be together with another person. And Jung says this is an integral part of individuation to develop oneself.
One cannot sit alone at home and individuate and become oneself. He says, no, this happens through other people and This is something that not a lot of people know, and this is also what Jung does not talk about so much. But he says, yeah, like, integrating our psyche is something that happens with and through other people.
And this is why it's necessary to have relationships and, yeah, long-term stable relationships to learn more about oneself and to become oneself. And psychologically-wise, I think we feel this, and this is why This movie is liked because it's showing that pretty well in both of their individual journeys.
And yeah, that would conclude my presentation part about Runaway Bride and the psychological underpinnings and what Jung would say to Runaway Bride. And I want to thank you for your time and attention, and I hope you learned something. And now I'm really curious about the discussion part and get your thoughts. Thank you.